life is about graduating and sometimes
graduating sucks let me tell you why see
graduating means we go from being in
high school life is easy it's good and
you go to college you don't want to come
to class don't come to class life is
about graduating you're used to having a
w-2 somebody pays you a paycheck then
you want to go do 1090 and like oh my
gosh i don't have a boss but this is
10.99 it's very hard you're 10.99 you're
making your own money but then you want
to go open up your own business you have
a lease you have employees you have you
know lawsuits you have healthcare
workers come oh this is a lot of
headache then you start having your own
business but you're not a good ceo or
you're single you graduate to being
married you're married you graduate to
having kids you have kids
it's all about graduating and every time
you graduate to the next level
graduation must come with positive
changes if you don't make the right
changes then you go back to what you
were before so maybe it's time you
graduate your current level